Langen: My name is Casey Langen.
I'm a software engineer
for amazon.com,
and I wrote the Amazon MP3
Store App for Android.
Let me show you how it works.
So you'll notice
on the home screen
there's easy access
to all the major features.
There are the Top 100 Albums,
Top 100 Songs.
These are updated hourly.
You can Browse by Genre
or you can Search,
and Search is what I'll demo
for you today.
So I'm gonna tap
the Search button,
and I'm gonna select Hendrix.
I wanna look at some
Jimi Hendrix albums.
I'm interested in purchasing
this Blues album,
so I'm going to tap it.
I'll be presented with...
an album detail page
which contains all the tracks
on the album.
I can scroll around in here
and preview tracks in place.
So I can just tap
Voodoo Chile Blues.
[song playing]
Okay, I like this song,
so I'm gonna go ahead
and purchase it.
So I'm going to press
this price button.
I will tap again to confirm.
As soon as the purchase
completes,
my downloads will be cued,
and I'll be presented
with this download screen.
And as soon as this track
finishes downloading,
it'll be automatically added
to the music app.
So...
Select Albums.
Notice here's the Blues Album.
And here's Voodoo Chile Blues.
[song playing]
So that's how you use
the Amazon MP3 Store App.
Amazon is really interested
in reaching as many people
on as many different platforms
as possible,
so the move to the mobile market
seemed very logical.
Android made that really easy.
We used the Apache HTTP client
to download metadata
from our web services.
We use--make extensive use
of the ListView.
In fact, I think
we use the ListView
in every activity
in our application.
And we also use
the MediaPlayer quite a bit
for song previews.